>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Michelle Cadoree Bradley: Hello.
I'm Michelle Cadoree Bradley.
A Science Reference Specialist
here in the Science, Technology,
and Business Division of
the Library of Congress.
I'd like to welcome you to the
10th season of our collaboration
with NASA Goddard and today is
the third lecture of the eight
that we have planned
for this season.
There's a list available outside
of the theater -- of the room.
And you can always check
our website or subscribe
to our blog to see what's coming up.
Today, Dr. Jason Dworkin, Chief
of the Astrochemistry laboratory
at NASA's Goddard Space
Flight Center in Greenbelt,
Maryland will discuss
the OSIRIS-REx --
I'm making lots of
eye movements here.
Cut that one out.
Anyway, it is the first U.S.
mission that will return samples
from an asteroid to Earth.
The findings will highlight the
physical and chemical properties
of material from asteroid Bennu.
The Asteroid is a remnant
of the early solar system
and should contain
clues to its formation.
Online, I found a description that
said it was "born from the rubble
of a violent collision, hurled
through space for millions of years
and dismembered by the
gravity of planets."
Isn't it just thrilling
to think of it.
[ Laughter ]
Dr. Dworkin has a Ph.D. in
Biochemistry from the University
of California - San Diego.
And his research objective is to
assess the organic species available
for the origin and
early evolution of life,
with a focus on understanding the
extraterrestrial input and origin
of molecules relevant for life.
Please join me in welcoming
Dr. Dworkin.
[ Applause ]
>> Jason Dworkin: Thank you so much.
What a great summary of the mission.
I think I'm done.
[ Laughter ]
So, OSIRIS-REx is the first mission
to return samples from an asteroid.
It's also the largest sample return
of any object since Apollo 17.
I'll be happy to talk
to you about that today.
As you may know, planets and
stars are born from nebula.
And within those, protoplanetary
disks form and out
of which, planets condense.
These are vast disks of
gas and dust, ice and rocks
and organic material
that then coalesce
into planets and leave
behind rubble.
Some of these rubble is large
and which is responsible
for the formation of the moon.
Other bits are still there
in the form of asteroids.
This is the view that you've
often seen of the solar system
with the sun and the planets
and the asteroid belts
and the other planets
and the Kuiper belt.
And there was a presentation
recently about the flyby Pluto.
And even further away from
that are the Oort cloud
where some comets come from.
Now this is not scale.
On this scale -- this is a fun
little website -- 1pixelmoon --
and this is the scale of
that same solar system.
You can see how far
things are apart.
And space is vast.
Anyway, so planets accrete
and life somehow forms.
And from that, all life
on the Earth is related.
And so, you are here and your
close ancestors are slime molds
and fungus.
[ Laughter ]
And we're distant ancestors --
are bacteria and actinobacteria.
But we all share the
same fundamental biology.
The same fundamental
architecture of how life works.
And that is all hidden somewhere in
the ancient history of the Earth.
This is an excerpt from a --
[inaudible] cartoon from XKCD.
It's a cartoon you should read.
If you don't, you really should.
Nearly four and a half billion years
ago, Earth was -- had liquid water.
All but the crust older than 3.5
billion years has been recycled
into the mantle by subduction.
A billion years of the
stratigraphic record,
the memory of the hills,
is forever lost to us.
What was it like four
billion years ago?
Earth, what secrets do you have?
Come closer.
I'll never tell.
[ Laughter ]
All we have are these stupid
tantalizing zircons to tell us
that the -- about four billion years
ago, there was oceans on the Earth
and scars on the face of
the moon that tells me
about the bombardment
history of the ancient Earth.
The Earth is mute on its early
history so we have to look
to asteroids and comets, meteorites
which delivered water and organics.
But the problem is -- I mean,
you search for meteorites.
You find them on the ground.
In the dirt or on the ice.
You don't know where they came from.
And they become contaminated.
So, if you're afraid of
getting the rotten apple,
don't go to the barrel.
Go to the tree.
From the Untouchables.
And so, send a mission out to find
a connection between the left-overs
of the early formations
of the solar system --
meteorites which are disconnected
from their origins on the ground.
You can send a robot.
NASA is known for human exploration
which is very exciting
and very important.
But robotic exploration
is a little bit easier
because robots don't
insist on coming back home.
[ Laughter ]
And it's -- if a robot dies,
it's sad but not tragic.
And they are smaller, cheaper, and
they don't require an annual salary
when they're out exploring
the cosmos.
And so, we know -- I
showed you a little bit
about how the clouds are formed
from diffuse medium,
condensed into planets.
And from that you have
information on the preserved
in the form of asteroids and comets.
And so, what we know about the
[inaudible] medium from observations
and simulations in the laboratory.
We know about the ancient Earth --
we know from simulations because the
Earth is mute on its early history.
To get a real understanding
about what was there,
you have to have sample
return from objects.
And sample return are -- this
is every sample return mission
that has ever been flown.
Starting in Apollo 11 up through
OSIRIS-REx was launch just
in September.
And these are missions which
bring back samples to the Earth
to be studied for generations.
So, for example, in my
laboratory, I have a woman
who recently published a paper
on Apollo 16 and 17 samples.
She was not yet born when the
samples were collected using
techniques that were not designed;
asking questions thought unaskable
when the missions were
conceived of in the 1960s.
And so, that is the
power of sample return.
That you can interrogate
samples using instruments
that have either not
yet been invented.
And so, I ask young
people where they --
what they will be doing when the
sample comes back in seven years.
Would they be making decisions
that could set themselves
in positions to analyze the sample?
They can think about
questions that we are not
yet smart enough to ask right now.
You can also fly instruments
which cannot be miniaturized.
Excuse me.
So, for example, this is
a synchrotron beam-line.
And here is a scale bar.
This is a car.
And so, it's very hard to imagine
how you can miniaturize something
like that to fit into a five-meter
ferrying -- to fly to space.
Other instruments give
you the analytical power
that you can see tremendous
detail that you can never see
on an actual flight mission.
Probably because once
you design a mission,
the instruments become static.
You cannot change them as you come
up with new ideas and new questions.
You can if you bring a sample back
and can interrogate it on Earth.
So, we're going to an asteroid.
This is every asteroid that's
been visited by a spacecraft.
Some are large like the dwarf planet
series down to something very small
like Bennu -- which is
the one we're going --
which is half a kilometer across.
And there are a lot of asteroids.
This month, there have been 95
near Earth asteroids discovered.
There are 714,000 asteroids
known as of yesterday.
And so, we can see that -- this
is the main belt of asteroids.
Here is Jupiter and there --
here's the Trojan asteroids.
Mars. Earth.
Venus. Mercury and the sun.
These red ones are Earth
crossing asteroids.
Again, the green ones.
The main belt.
And blue ones, Trojans.
And then, of course,
other objects further out.
How do you pick an
asteroid to get to?
Well, when we were
conceiving of OSIRIS-REx,
at the time there were
only 500,000 asteroids.
Not the 700,000 we have today.
Of those, 7000 are
near Earth crossing
which means you have the chance of
getting to and from the asteroid
within the lifespan of a scientist
or of a NASA program executive.
Of those, 192, you can get there
and back again with a rocket
that we can conceivably
build and fund.
Of those, 26 have diameters
greater than 200 meters.
That's important for two reasons.
One is asteroids with diameters
that are smaller than that.
I've got a model out
there you can play with.
Smaller than that,
they spin very fast.
Up to one revolution per minute.
And that has two problems.
One is that the loose regolith on
the surface get thrown off and lost
which means it's very hard
to sample the loose rock
on the surface because
it's not there.
Even more important,
it spins so fast
that you can imagine the proximity
operations of a spacecraft trying
to match orbits -- match spin
rate with an object spinning
at one revolution per
minute is challenging.
Of those 26, five are carbon rich.
We're interested in
the origin of life.
The early solar system.
The organic inventory.
And so, we need an object
that is especially very dark
and has evidence of
organics and volatiles.
Of those, Bennu is our choice.
And that's because Bennu is a class
B object which is similar to Themis
which is a main belt asteroid
that has ices and organics.
[Inaudible] albedo,
very low density.
Lots of evidence of loose rocks.
Very well understood
orbital parameters.
And, by the way, it is a potentially
hazardous object with chance
of hitting the late 22nd century.
So, lots of time to prepare.
Not to worry.
But the most important
reason is it's --
the most extensively
characterized object
that a spacecraft has
never been to yet.
We had a long campaign starting in
1999 when it was first discovered.
And it was observed by numerous
ground and space based telescopes
so we have a very good understanding
of what this object is so that,
that was we can plan a
mission that is low risk
and has a high chance of success.
The model that's out on the table,
you can play with is
from Arecibo data.
That's the giant telescope
in Puerto Rico.
That generated the shape model
and that's what the 3D printed
model is, is this very shape.
And in contrast, the Comet
67P/Churyumov-Gerasimenko --
the comet which the Rosetta
mission is orbiting --
it was too far away
to have radar imaging.
So, it had -- light curves
that could give a model --
turned out to be -- the shape was
actually quite different from --
we could get from light curves.
We'll know when we get there
but we have high expectations
that it will be basically
round shaped.
Very much like this.
There could be some
stretching in either direction
but will not have these crazy lobes.
So, it will be -- it should be
a very safe object to orbit.
And a very safe object to sample
from within the usual risks
of doing something in
space which is hard.
OSIRIS-REx is a large team.
It's lead by PI Professor
Dante Lauretta.
Right here with mascot, Pen-REx.
[ Laughter ]
This is just the science team.
There's an even larger technical
team of engineers and technicians
who have built and
designed the spacecraft.
OSIRIS-REx -- the name is an
acronym as most things in NASA are.
It stands for Origins,
Spectral Interpretation,
Resource Identification,
Security, Regolith Explorer.
This in animation --
which I pause for some --
of the sampling device and
sampling action happening.
The most important thing is
to return a pristine sample
which is extremely difficult
because pristine is impossible.
Totally clean is impossible.
But you can focus on what matters
to you and minimize contamination
within a reasonable cost
and not waste your time cleaning
things that don't matter.
And not waste your efforts
by letting things become
dirty that do matter.
Contamination studies
start on day one.
And so, from the start of
the concept of the mission,
we were concerned with making sure
that we have a pristine sample.
But, at the same time, the
spacecraft has to work.
I like to say that
if the sample fell
in the toilet, it wouldn't flush.
[ Laughter ]
So, having a contaminated sample
is better than having no sample,
but I really, really
want a clean sample
to understand the questions
related to the origins of biology.
So, I asked the science team.
Give me a list of the elements
that you really care about
and we shouldn't get
on the spacecraft.
And they gave me these ones in red.
[ Laughter ]
So, I put this up and
someone said, "Oh, actually,
polonium is really cool too.
So, don't put any polonium
on there either."
Like, okay.
Come one. We're going to make
the spacecraft out of neptunium
and then, I'll violate our thermal
requirements so we can't do that.
Plus, it would be too expensive and
dangerous and horrible in every way.
Plus, you ask the organic
people what do you want?
Well, basically, anything that is
an organic compound, we can't have.
So, what we did is we took this and
came up with representative species.
Amino acids, limiting hydrazine,
carbon, potassium, nickel, tin,
nonindium, and lead as indicators
of other [inaudible] elements
for geological processes
of our chemical processes.
Came up with a limit that made
sense to science based on meteorites
and then turned that limit into
engineering -- which makes sense --
people who actually
built the spacecraft.
Beyond having a limit
on contamination,
we also have contamination
control --
that lead to contamination
knowledge.
If you have a spacecraft that
meets our control limits,
you can still have some dirt.
Understanding what that
dirt is is important.
And so, we have monitor in
place that are on the spacecraft
that we analyze when it comes back.
And [inaudible] in the clean room
that the science team is analyzing
and [inaudible] the bill so we
can understand the low levels
of materials that are present
and that being launched
and sent back to Earth.
We also have an archiving
campaign of materials that are used
in the production of the
spacecraft so we can --
the science team can
analyze it when it comes back
in parallel with the samples.
We can understand if
they were an issue.
So, for example, I worked
on the Stardust mission.
And turned out -- to the
surprise of the science team --
that something called
Synlube was used
as a demolding agent in the aerogel.
Stardust had these
gelatin-like molds of aerogel
that captured the comet dust.
And to get out of the mold, they
had to have an unmolding agent.
Nobody mentioned that.
And that turns out to be
something like brake fluid
which is this horrible
mixture of organic compounds.
It turned out that -- Synlube
100 was used on stardust.
The company changed names.
The records were lost to arson.
Products rights were
sold from the company.
And the -- it was actually, I think,
the owner's son was interviewed
and suspected that Synlube 1000
was actually the same formulation
as what was used on Stardust
which was launched years before.
So as a result, the science team
spent six months studying Synlube
instead of studying
cometary material
to understand what it
was doing to our samples.
And even so, there's
still some uncertainty.
And so, this is a mistake that
we have learned from and so all
of these, we have very tight
controls over what is being used,
good communication
between the science team,
the engineering team,
and the technical team.
And things like these
that you have to have
to make your spacecraft work --
we have an archive in Houston,
the [inaudible] Harbor lab where --
so when you write a proposal to
get some of the OSIRIS-REx sample,
you get one milligram of
OSIRIS-REx sample, and I would also
like one milligram of
[inaudible] to understand
if that could have contributed
to these things I'm seeing.
So, we have all of that.
It's being analyzed by
the science team now.
And just like the sample, 75% is
preserved for future generations.
Anyway, enough on contamination.
My pet little thing
on the spacecraft.
Our primary goal is to return and
analyze a sample -- pristine sample.
The sample comes back in a
stardust like sample return capsule.
Shown here.
Returns in Utah September
24, 2023 at 8:53 a.m. --
in time for the Sunday
morning talk shows.
[ Laughter ]
Actually, that time is
dictated by orbital mechanics.
We have nothing to do with that,
but it just happens
to work out that way.
But anyway, set your [inaudible].
Number two is to understand
how the sample fits in context.
So, for that that, we'll be imaging
and especially analyzing
the sampling site
down to the sub centimeter so we
have a good idea of -- excuse me.
Of how the sample that we
got back to Earth compares
with the immediate location
and the context of that sample.
Something that has
not been done before
on any sample return
mission since Apollo.
We will also understand
Bennu as a geologic object
by understanding the
geology and dynamics
and spectroscopy of
the entire satellite.
We also understand the interaction
between the asteroid
and thermal properties.
And so, this is a light mill
which you may have played with.
I think they sell them in gift
shops around here as well.
This is like -- not quite
the Yarkovsky Effect --
where light hits a dark surface.
And in space, what happens
is the light pressure hits,
the dark surface is absorbed,
the object is rotating,
and the light is emitted on
the night side and that acts
as a low intensity thruster.
And that changes the
orbit of the object away
from its Keplerian predicted orbits
which is why we'll give impact
probabilities for asteroids --
there's this error
associated with it --
that's because of this extra
term that's related to the color
and topography of the asteroid.
And light now is a little bit of a
cheat because -- or radiometer --
because there's actually
a rarified atmosphere
so what's actually happening is the
light is hitting the black surface,
it's warming up the gas in front of
it, and that acts as the thruster.
Because otherwise, it
wouldn't spin nearly
as fast using just purely
the Yarkovsky Effect.
And finally, there are
700,000 asteroids --
NASA is not spending a
billion dollars to go
to every single one of them.
We're going to go to one
object and try and understand
that from a point source
down to the molecular level.
And so, by using that
information, we can then apply
with what we can see with
telescopes the other 700,000 objects
and understand how they behave.
When the sample comes back, we'll
be using a hypothesis based study
to understand -- to try and pull
back to the pre-solar history,
protoplanetary disc, geologic
activity, the evolution of Regolith
as the object has moved
through the solar system,
through it's dynamical
history and then finally,
the impact that the spacecraft
has had on the sample,
including the contamination impact.
We have a spacecraft.
It's like most spacecraft,
it has a science deck
that has various cameras
and spectrometers.
We have solar arrays
like most space crafts.
What most spacecraft don't
have is a sample return capsule
and a three-meter long arm
that collects the sample.
The payload contains a number of
instruments that scan from the X-ray
to the radar wavelengths.
From the high-end antenna to
the student built experiments.
OVIRS is -- this is the
image of the spacecraft.
It is built, it is shipped
to Kennedy Space Center.
And this is -- the orientation
of the flight deck here is OVIRS.
It's a spectrometer.
OTES is a different spectrometer.
We have a camera suite
that will give us --
from telescope image down
to a microscopic imager.
Well, almost microscopic.
We have a light arm which
would give us the topography.
Student experiments
for X-ray mapping --
to give us elemental composition.
And the high gain antenna which will
provide our gravity field mapping.
The core of the mission
is [inaudible] the sample.
This is the sampling
mechanism called TAGSAM.
It is essentially like
a car air filter.
The initial design was
actually called Muucav,
which is vacuum spelled backwards.
[ Laughter ]
Us of the vacuum of space and blows
a jet of nitrogen gas and instead
of -- like in a vacuum cleaner,
you have vacuum getting sucked --
vacuum sucks material out.
You have the nitrous gas
blowing into the [inaudible] it
and getting sucked out into
space through the air filter.
It has been tested extensive
-- this is fine -- extensively.
From having a simulated
spacecraft and an air bearing --
this is, kind of, like an air
hockey table impacting surfaces
at different slopes and thicknesses
to see how the sampling occurs,
to operating the sampling
mechanism on a microgravity flight
on the KC 165 vomit comet to
make sure that the sampling works
under microgravity, to using the
same air bearing table to make sure
that we can stow the sample head
into the sample return capsule.
And then there is a video of
the sampling head being locked
in the samples return capsule with
three switches and then back off
to make sure that it is in place.
This will be a very
similar image as we'll get
from the cameras onboard
the spacecraft to make sure
that the head is actually locked in
place because once we stow the head,
we sever the joint,
cutting it off so that
when we close the sample return
capsule up to bring it home,
this is a one-time only action.
Now we have nitrene bottles we
can actually collect three times
if we need to.
We only want to collect once.
But if there's an anomaly,
we can go back and try again,
and then again if we have to.
But we want to collect
once to get our 60 grams
and as much as two kilograms.
And these test flights, we've
[inaudible] at least 150 grams.
Usually, more like half a kilogram.
And the two kilograms is based on
packing the head entirely full.
That's how much we can carry.
And that's happened on occasion.
The OSIRIS-REx has been
through a lot of history.
The first concept was in 2004.
That's when I started
working the project.
And wrote a proposal,
and was not selected.
In fact, no one was
selected that year.
And then, we regrouped and
wrote a better proposal
with a better concept.
And that went to a first
cut-off selection, and then wrote
up a more detailed proposal
and then that was not selected.
And then, we needed
-- it became clear
that a sample return mission
requires more resources
than was allowable in
the discovery program.
So, we went to the
new frontiers program
which is a larger cost
gap -- PL admission.
Wrote another proposal.
Made it to Phase A which is --
this is Volume two of
the phase A proposal.
All 90 copies required
by the review team.
It's since gone digital but --
[ Laughter ]
Way back in 2009, it was
paper -- if you can imagine.
Site visits; selections;
lots and lots of meetings.
And then, we actually
[inaudible] implementation.
And so, the ATLO which
is the Assembly, test,
and launch operations --
started March 23, 2015.
This is the spacecraft being
put into a thermovac chamber.
That is a chamber to simulate
the vacuum and coldness and heat
of space to make sure
that the systems function.
More reviews, and then last
week, the spacecraft was shipped
to Kennedy Space Center and unloaded
and is undergoing its final testing
now until it's ready to launch.
And Atlas V 411.
And that's code for 3-meter
fairing, one solid rocket motor,
and one single engine centaur stage.
The window opens at 7:05 p.m.
eastern time, September 8, 2016.
Come if you can.
And because it's hurricane season,
we have a 35-day launch window
so that if something bad
happens, we have lots of time
to regroup and try again.
So, after launch, we depart
the Earth and then have --
Earth gravity assist one year
later to change inclination.
Get them on the same plane as Bennu.
And then, we approach the asteroid
initially as a point source
and then it becomes more and
more an actual geologic object.
We enter an orbit which
is a semi-stable orbit.
I guess in this case, Bennu is so
small that the pull of gravity is
about equal to the pressure of the
sun so you have to balance and,
basically, surf in the gravity field
and the solar field between the two
which is why that it's very
important that our center of mass
and our center of area be
coaligned in the spacecraft.
Once we have understood the --
Let's try that again.
The asteroid better,
we'll be on detail survey
to understand our favorite
sampling sites.
Down select to one sampling site.
Do a rehearsal to make sure
that we can do every single step
of the operation of sampling.
Because getting close to an
asteroid is a little bit scary.
You're only going to want to
do it once -- the sampling.
So, that means we have lots
of margin for rehearsing it --
that it's matching the
orbits, matching the heights.
Getting very, very close.
Everything but sampling
until we're ready to sample.
And then something happens where --
Because it's orbiting the sun,
the asteroid gets very close to --
well, closer to the sun than we
would like and so there's a risk
of the sample will get
hot after we collect it.
We collect it in the
sampling system,
and then it's sitting outside in
the spacecraft on the sampling arm
for up to a month because
as I mentioned,
the stowing operation is
a once-and-done operation.
We want to make sure
that we do it right.
That means that it's
sitting out in sunlight
and that could get it too hot.
So, we have this period here after
the lying in the sand - LITS --
[ Laughter ]
Where we will stand down and
wait until it's cool enough
to actually perform the sampling.
If everything goes perfectly,
we can sample earlier.
But, there are things called
safe modes that spacecraft go
through where if you have, like, a
computer glitch, the spacecraft goes
to safe mode and resets itself.
And this happens all the time.
On average, about twice
a year or so.
Let's say, if the spacecraft
is orbing Mars, that happens.
And then, fine, you're
still orbiting Mars.
But we're near an object
that has almost no gravity.
And so, when we hit safe mode, our
instructions are drive to the sun.
Just burn away.
So. that means that you're now --
you've gone from over
here to over here.
We have to approach
the asteroid again
and understand what's happening.
And so, that takes extra time
and so we've allocated lots
of extra time margin to
be able to reset ourselves
and get the engineering team --
the navigation team to understand
where the spacecraft is relative
to the asteroid and become same.
And then it will approach again.
So, this could take as much as month
after a safe mode,
unlike a couple of days.
And so, we have all
that margin built in.
And then -- let's see
if we can get this to --
[ Music ]
>> The milky way.
Home to billions of starts
rising and setting over billions
of worlds including our own.
In this vast expanse, how
did our Sun, the Earth,
and the planets come to be?
In recent decades, our understanding
of the solar system's
evolution has greatly improved,
but deep questions remain.
To answer those questions,
astronomers are preparing
to visit someplace very small.
Asteroid Bennu.
A lump of rock and organic
material, the early building blocks
of the solar system,
of Earth, of us.
Bennu is a time capsule, and
its journey takes us way,
way back...four and
a half billion years.
The raw ingredients of
Bennu, and our solar system,
originated in a stellar nursery:
a vast cloud of hydrogen,
helium, and dust.
Our own Sun doesn't yet exist.
Nearby are hot stars like this
one, quickly burning up its fuel...
and destroying itself in a colossal
explosion called a supernova.
The explosion destabilizes our
cloud, causing it to collapse.
In the geologic blink of an eye,
a hundred thousand years, gravity,
and angular momentum flatten
the cloud into a swirling disc.
In the center, where molecules crash
together tightest, a proto-star revs
up to incredible pressures
and temperatures.
Deep within the disc, clumps of
dust not much larger than a grain
of wheat are flash
heated into droplets
of molten rock, called chondrules.
The source of this
heat remains a mystery.
Chondrules are destined to
become the building blocks
of the solar system.
Coaxed by gravity and
turbulence, the chondrules clump.
They grow into the first asteroids,
into mountains, into planets.
The asteroids are rubble piles of
rock, metal, ice, and organics.
This large asteroid is
the parent body of Bennu,
a proto-planet whose
size we can only guess.
Closer to the proto-star,
a planet begins to form.
And then...dawn in the solar system.
The proto-star undergoes fusion
and ignites, revealing our Sun.
But the solar system
is far from finished.
Jupiter most likely forms
near its outer edge,
but just 500 million years
after the Sun ignites,
some believe that it
slowly moves inward.
Its massive gravity
ripples the asteroid belt,
disrupting countless
asteroids and comets,
flinging them toward the Sun.
[ Music ]
They rain down on the
inner planets, hammering
and re-melting large
portions of their crust.
Did these impacts also
deliver organics and water,
key ingredients for life?
Back in the asteroid belt,
Bennu's parent body is lucky,
it survives this period
of heavy bombardment.
The solar system cools and calms.
Jupiter and its many moons assume
the orbits that we see today.
Billions of years of quiet follow...
[ Impact ]
More or less.
Then a billion years ago, one
theory suggests a collision shatters
the proto-planet.
[ Loud explosion ]
[ Music ]
Some of the debris loosely coalesces
into a new, smaller body: Bennu.
But Bennu will not stay in place.
Dull, non-reflective, it
slowly migrates toward the Sun.
Solar heating turns its warm side
into a low-intensity thruster.
Through millions of years,
Bennu's orbit gradually tightens,
until it interacts with Saturn's
gravity, altering its trajectory,
and hurling it into
the inner solar system.
[ Music ]
Close encounters with
Earth and Venus follow.
Their gravitational tugs may
have repeatedly stretched
and reformed Bennu turning it inside
out and pulling off loose material.
As a result, it has no
satellites of its own...until now.
Today, NASA is sending a
spacecraft called OSIRIS-REx
to explore Bennu and
retrieve a sample.
Why? Bennu has survived its
long journey and settled
into a near-Earth orbit, bringing
its secrets within our reach.
Now it is ready to teach us more
about the solar system's history,
its formation, its evolution, and
our own place among the stars.
[ Music fades ]
>> Jason Dworkin: Now, you should be
very well armed to understand some
of the deeper meanings of this
presentation -- of this video.
[ Beeping ]
The video itself it --
it's very nicely done.
It has, you'll notice scientists
believe, one theory proposes --
these are all things that
OSIRIS-REx will be testing.
These are all testable
hypothesis that are built
into the mission summed
up in this video.
And now, you know what a
low-intensity thruster is --
that's Yarkovsky Effect.
You know about how the origin
of the solar system could
have indicated formation
of organics delivered
to the early Earth.
How this asteroid can
contain materials that we want
to understand for generations
to come.
And how now you can become
involved and learn more
about OSIRIS-REx at our website.
The PI's blog which has a lot
of information, great pictures.
And all kinds of other
social media sites.
And I thank you for your attention.
[ Applause ]
>> Michelle Cadoree Bradley: I just
know that after that we have lots
of questions so please feel free to
ask your questions to Dr. Dworkin.
Please repeat their
questions as they come up.
>> Jason Dworkin: Yes.
>> Michelle Cadoree
Bradley: Thank you.
ii
>> Jason Dworkin: Yes.
>> Your collector.
>> It looked like you're blowing
nitrogen gas and using the vacuum
of outer space to make it a vacuum.
>> Jason Dworkin: Mm-hmm.
>> When you pull it off, how do you
make sure the particles don't stay
in the filter and not
go back in -- out.
>> Jason Dworkin: So, the question
is how does the collector retain the
material that gets inside?
>> Yes.
>> Jason Dworkin: There is
a Mylar check valve that's
where material comes in and it
won't fall out of check valve
when it gets trapped
next to the filter.
That's how.
>> I have a second question.
>> Jason Dworkin: Okay.
>> In your picture of your
spacecraft when it was orbiting,
I didn't see a propulsion
system to return [inaudible].
>> Jason Dworkin: We
have a propulsion system.
Here's the monoprop tank.
You can see shaded
by the solar rays,
here are monoprop hydrogen
thrusters.
And this is how we do
all of our transfers.
This is our main engines.
We have tiny little
thrusters that help us
to navigate around the asteroid.
We have a main engine which
will get us back to Earth.
What happens is when we get close to
Earth, these sample return caps --
we divert towards the Earth.
Release the sample return capsule.
It spins up and so it's rotation
stabilized and enters over Utah
with less than 1:1,000,000 chance
of damaging life or property
because it lands in the Utah Test
and Training Range
outside Salt Lake City.
And then, the spacecraft
itself diverts away from Earth
and goes into heliocentric orbit.
So, the spacecraft has thrusters.
Yes, sir.
>> Why are the asteroids located
in this tiny belt around the sun --
[Inaudible comment]
>> Jason Dworkin: So why
are the asteroids located
in the asteroid belt?
It's really -- gravitational pull
of Jupiter is the main source.
A good question is why are
there any planets at all?
Why isn't it just gas and dust?
Gravitationally, they tend to
accrete and in the asteroid belt,
there's enough gravitational
disruption
from Jupiter -- as I understand.
Again, I'm a chemist so the
orbital dynamics is a hobby,
not a specialty.
But it's too unstable there
for a planet to actually form.
And so, that's a belt
that is retained
by Jupiter and Solar interactions.
>> Thank you.
>> Jason Dworkin: Yes, sir.
>> How do you [inaudible]
be sure that the surface
of the asteroid is dusty and would
respond to the capture mechanism
and not shiny and smooth?
>> Jason Dworkin: All
right, so how do we know
that the asteroid has
regolith on it?
We have thermal inertia
measurements taken from --
From the -- primarily, the
Spitzer Space telescope,
as well as some other telescopes,
that give us a thermal
inertia of the asteroid.
Thermal inertia is how long it
takes for a solid to cool off
when it gets out of the sunlight.
And so, compare the thermal
inertia of beach sand versus rocks.
And beach sand cools off faster
because it's finer grain.
And so, you can use that
to tell the grain size.
Average grain size is about two
centimeters which is perfect
for fitting inside of
our sampling system.
And there's bound to be dust.
That's also why we have contact
pads on the sampling system so that
if the worst happens and
we don't get rocks inside,
we'll get dust on the
surface collect.
[Inaudible] indication of what,
also, the surface is like.
[Inaudible comment]
>> Jason Dworkin: The question is,
is the dust on the
surface representative?
Boy, if I knew that,
we wouldn't have to go.
[ Laughter ]
And we actually have conversa-,
it will be a very interesting day
when we choose the sampling site.
Let us imagine that you have the
surface of Bennu when it's all black
and there's one white rock.
Do you want to sample the one
white rock because it's weird
or the black part because
it's normal?
Again, that will be an
interesting conversation
and that's a PI led mission and
so there's a council that reports
to the PI, who makes the
decision, who then gets concurrence
from the Associate
Administrator of NASA.
And so, there's a bureaucracy to
make sure that we make a decision
that is equally unpleasant to all.
[ Laughter ]
Yes. In the back.
>> How do you match the surface?
I assume that you're going
to have to be stationary
over whatever the surface is
that you're going to sample.
How do you match its orbit?
I assume you know which
way the spin is, et cetera?
>> Jason Dworkin: The
orbital parameters
of Bennu was a 4.2-hour day.
It's retrograde orbit.
We know that already.
When the spacecraft gets close,
we'll be able to match it
very precisely because it is
such a small object, it's really,
more like a docking maneuver
than it is an orbiting maneuver.
And so, we can use all of
the tiny little thrusters all
over the spacecraft to
help us orient ourselves
to match the orbital rotation
when we go into our rehearsals --
to make sure that we
can do that properly.
And then, actually match the
orientation on the surface.
We'll be generating four maps
to help us choose our sample.
The first map is the safety map.
Make sure we have a
site that is actually --
will not endanger the spacecraft.
The second map is the
sampleability map to make sure
that we have sample
sizes at that location
which can fit in our
sampling system.
Measuring again the thermal
inertia and taking images.
After that, we have the
deliverability map to make sure
that the navigators can
get us to that spot.
Like it's not, say in the North
Pole, where the rotation is
such that you actually have to
spin the space craft too fast.
And then, after that
is the science map
that gives us the most
exciting science.
The black rock versus the
white rock for example.
And so, the addition of these four
maps will help us decide the safest,
most sampleable, most deliverable,
most exciting site we can get.
Yes, sir.
>> How do you discriminate between
material that has accumulated
on to this object over times
[inaudible] and you're passing
through the different
medium as opposed
to what real content
of the rock represents?
Is there a way of finding that or --
>> Jason Dworkin: So, the
question is how do we differentiate
between original Bennu material
and material accreted
from other objects?
That will be looking
at the minerology.
Looking at the detailed
elemental abundancies and I stop
at distributions of the
sample when we get back.
They're both very interesting
stories.
So, for example, the Almahata Sitta
meteorite that landed, or well,
crashed into Sudan
in -- what was it?
2010 or so.
No. 2008. 2008 -- TC3
was the asteroid
and was the only time an
asteroid was observed in space
and [inaudible] characterized.
And then hit the Earth
and it was collected.
So, it's both an asteroid
and a meteorite.
Almahata Sitta, 2008, TC3.
Anyway, that turns out to be
a [inaudible] of a whole bunch
of different kinds of
meteorites thrown together
in a really weird way.
And what exciting science that
will be if that's what Bennu is.
But just as with Almahata Sitta,
we'll be able to determine
that by looking at the rocks.
Yes, sir?
>> If you were to hit the jackpot,
get everything you want to know
out of this, what would that be?
>> Jason Dworkin: So, what is the
ultimate success for this mission?
Well, nothing less than
original life, of course.
[ Laughter ]
It's to either prove or disprove
theories on solar system formation,
on are there [inaudible]
that led to the timing
of the proto-solar nebula.
What organic compounds are present?
Are there excess of
left-handed amino acids?
Something that I specialize in that
led to, perhaps, the origin of life.
Are there -- are those amino
acids a biological type
but not contamination?
Are these -- the sugar
contents -- nucleus basis.
There's a wealth of chemistry that
we cannot yet answer from rocks
on the ground because
of contamination
that this will help us understand.
[Inaudible comment]
>> Jason Dworkin: So, this is
comparing OSIRIS-REx to ARM,
the Asteroid Redirect Mission.
OSIRIS-REx is a PI led mission
that was -- getting there.
That was selected on the
New Frontiers line in 2009.
It is a science driven mission
to return a sample for
purpose of science.
ARM is very much like
Gemini, it's a way to rehearse
and practice having
astronauts operate in space.
ARM is an engineering
exercise directed by the agency
to understand how to
work on objects in space
to help up get closer to Mars.
That is not science drive,
that's technology driven.
If there is a science pay
off, then that's great.
But science is not the
driver of that mission.
In the case of OSIRIS-REx,
science is the driver.
And there might be some technology
pay offs in how to interact
with small bodies, but
the purpose is science.
So, they have entirely
different purposes.
They're also at pretty different
stages in their life cycle.
The OSIRIS-REx is built and about
to launch, ARM is still a concept.
Anyone else?
Yes, sir.
>> If asteroid are formed from
the same material as [inaudible],
why would we have different --
[Inaudible comment]
>> Jason Dworkin: So, it's -- if
the Earth and the asteroids came
from the same source, why
are they different now?
Well, for one thing,
the Earth melted.
And partly because of this gigantic
-- I can't get back to it --
this gigantic impact that formed the
moon, that totally melted the earth.
After that, life will find a way.
Life is pervasive.
It has totally dominated
the chemistry of the earth.
Geologic processing like subduction
has also dominated the crust
of the earth.
And so, between geology and life,
the earth is a highly-evolved
object.
There's not much left
of it that's primordial.
And these asteroids
have never melted.
And they've never seen life.
And they've never seen liquid water
-- at least not that we know of.
And they've certainly
never seen subduction.
And so, they contain
the untarnished history
of the early solar
system unlike the Earth
which has been totally rearranged.
And just has Mars has been
rearranged by its geologic history.
And Venus has been rearranged
by its geologic history.
Anyone else?
[Inaudible comment]
Pardon?
Oh, Bennu is an Egyptian bird god.
And so, OSIRIS-REx is the
acronym for the mission.
Egypt is kind of cool
and that's why we went
with the Egyptology reference.
And that was initially for
the early OSIRIS concepts
which were not funded.
OSIRIS-REx was the
big grander version.
Started as a joke.
The OSIRIS king.
And I guess that's
post-[inaudible] but whatever.
[ Laughter ]
And so, the joke stuck and we came
up with a backronym for
what REx stands for.
Regolith explorer.
And so, we had a contest to rename
101955 1999 RQ36 something a little
bit more palatable.
And a young man in North
Carolina came up with the name
and he's been given a ticket
to the launch to see it.
And so, he thought that the image
of the spacecraft reminded him a bit
of a bird which also led to a
parody song, Bennu and the Rex.
Which I will not sing here.
[ Laughter ]
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.